when you made the decision which was a
brilliant [ __ ] decision to come out
of the closet in a stand-up special
mm-hmm it's a brilliant idea
and
and you can only do it once really yeah
yeah
you know and it's like it's like um when
you decide to do that how do you prepare
for something like this or did you just
have it all in your head and said i'm
gonna go with it that special was about
me saying the things i was scared to say
uh it's all things that secrets secrets
but but more importantly things that
have personal consequence don't you
think for you coming out had to be
particularly hard because of your
religious background your mom's very
religious like you said you used to go
to church all the time like i'm sure
it just kills you that i say religion i
say me and my mom have a god-sized wall
between us you know that that that's the
the impossible
thing you know to navigate
and do you feel like you're banging your
head against the wall because you're
god's supposed to be about accepting
everyone and loving everyone and then
acceptance and not all this judgment and
and here it is the thing that's keeping
you
in the closet yeah yeah this god thing
yeah yeah and causing self-hate you know
like and that's like that that's what
was really destructive and and it's been
very very difficult it's like you know
i'm
i'm i'm trying to
you know trust fall into
[Music]
a new interpretation of religion right
because i do think it has value like i
haven't completely let go of it and i'm
trying to like
you know reinterpret it for me and i've
been trying to
get my mother to have some type of
openness to her interpretation of it and
and and it's hard it's a tricky thing
because people my mother not just people
my mother
holds on to religion because it's
got her through really rough times in
her life my mother grew up my mom's from
the projects and
you know grew up with no money and and
and and not
didn't make it very far from
the projects to the first house to the
house that she got married in and like
like
she needed god for
every step of her life
and
she didn't account for a gay son she
doesn't really know what to do with it i
can feel her being lost i want to work
with her
um
but
talking to her and not acknowledging
that part of myself
causes a reverberating effect of
self-hate
that i can't afford right now
so i i
added distance
i think it's important you added
distance in other words the woman this
woman who you were so close to
my mom used to talk every day she used
to you know uh
sing like
aretha say a little prayer before shows
if she was doing a show she would just
sing
just say hello
like kind of songs and
um yeah we talk every day every day and
we and we don't um
anymore because i don't want the
conversation to be fake i don't want to
have i'm also trying to eliminate that
from my life as i try and eliminate it
from my work and just be truthful you
got to protect yourself you can't take
you can't take a beating every day no
you know no you can't it's no no no no
it's it's hard it's hard but what the
beating is internal like the the hell is
like
shutting down and knowing i can't talk
about being gay not even that i want to
share anything so explicit with her it's
it's just that it's off the table
you know if any part of you were
unacknowledged if someone if if someone
in conversation just refused to
acknowledge you have a show
that would be a little weird right like
it's just for some reason you got to
talk around it like everything you can't
say it it's just it
it's hard not to be yourself
especially with someone you love so much
right you want me to read you the tech
there's a exchange from my dad
uh my dad hit me uh
yesterday
and he was like uh
so he's been he's been
he texted me after the special it was
very sweet my dad is now like playing uh
referee between me and my mom because we
haven't been speaking so he sent me a
text
uh just saying just checking in on you
are you okay love you
uh and then i said i'm okay i've been
doing shows uh
started playing wwe 2k me and my dad
watched uh wrestling together as a kid
and i was like i thought of you love you
too
oh and i was like kind of like
coyly inviting him to like
play the game with me or whatever like
trying to reach out uh he said i don't
have the wwe but if you want to play
madden sometime let me know glad you're
doing okay i'm like [ __ ] meet me
halfway bro like where are you
i want to play madden i want to play
wrestling anyway
uh anyway he said your mom called the
other day so take take some time to call
her
she loves you and she misses her baby
boy take care
all right and what i wrote back kind of
explains where where i am
i said i know i love her too
but her baby boy is now a big gay man
and i think we need some time to come to
terms with that
and that's where we are